ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show uh being recorded the day
that the Epstein names have leaked and
uh we're playing I want to play a little
clip
here from the good
people uh at
NBC
who are
always you know
incredibly focused
and focusing our attention exactly where
it should be and here we
are NBC
News uh This Is How They are filtering
the Epstein news for you found I should
mention none of this obviously suggests
any wrongdoing by the former president
suggests that he was involved in a crime
it's merely talking about his
connections to Epstein something that
has already again been out there but he
has obviously maintained uh his
innocence and denied any wrongdoing as
it relates to any abuse by people that
Epstein exploited Tom that interactions
that Clint God no thank God
I the
slander has to
stop and I thank God that
NBC has the guts to come out and say hey
just CA the president
was mentioned 50
times in the
deposition of a victim of a human
trafficker just because he might have
taken said human trafficker plane 25
times or whatever just because the human
trafficker uh best friend jzan Maxwell
was at the president's daughter's
wedding there is no wrongdoing none of
this
suggests any
wrongdoing by the president it's very
important that
NBC and and all the other news networks
that we know and trust come out and
first and
foremost defend the honor of the man
who's mentioned 50 times in the human
trafficking
uh
docks it's very important who will do it
if not
NBC who will do it who will come out and
you know
defend rightly defend this man who is
being maligned with such ugly
talk such ugly talk for no
reason none of this suggests any
wrongdoing by the pr none of it Play it
Again Play The the first couple of lines
again none of
this found I should mention none of this
obviously suggests any wrongdoing by the
former president suggest that he was
involved in crime with the human
trafficker being on the plane of the
human trafficker having the human
trafficker friend at the wedd none of it
suggests any wrongdoing none of it
suggest any wrongdoing it just happens
it's ju just
happens like
uh Chris Matthews who used to host hard
ball until I don't even know what
happened I don't know why they threw him
out I don't think he even did anything I
think he I don't know what he did I
think he made some inappropriate comment
to a woman in an elevator
whatever Chris Matthews his reaction to
the epine thing was like well all of
these politicians they're just they're
broke and they need rides around the
country so some of them end up in these
planes and Rich guys offer to fly them
around yeah this is
uh yeah Chris Matthews came out and said
like uh Hey guys the clintons can't
afford to Charter their own plane yet
they yet I can some now I can Charter a
private plane if I want to go perform at
s Splitters in Tampa
but the Bill and Hillary Clinton M
somehow can't afford a chartered plane
so they have to take the charity of uh
Jeffrey
Epstein uh Chris Matthews goes to get
around for their professional and
political
reasons they've become friends with the
wrong freaking people and these people
are frightening and they want something
they want the pr of hanging around a
politician so that was uh Chris Matthews
again somebody who works at NBC that was
his
way of understanding it is that it's a
big 90s movie
mixup where you end up on a plane with a
human trafficker at a at an island where
they're having sex orges with children
it's a big mixup you weren't supposed to
be there you just needed a ride it was
Planes Trains and Automobiles starring
the ex-president of the United States
and a bunch of 15year olds that's what
it was and anyone who thinks it's
anything else you're not you're crazy
because none of this suggests any
wrongdoing not one not any of it none of
it none of it this is the level of
gaslighting and I hate that word
but but it is but I will use it when it
suits my purposes and I will say that
this is a level of gaslighting that is
almost impressive the news now has to
tell you that your eyes and ears are
you're seeing the words and they're on
the paper but they have to then tell you
that none of the words actually are any
indication of what the words are
supposed to
mean like for example it would be like
me handing you a menu and then walking
over to your table a few minutes later
and going none of this is food and you
go well I don't understand you go well
it's just words on a paper none of it
suggests we have any of the food you go
wait but it's a menu saying you've got a
steak and mashed potatoes yeah but have
you seen any of it well no I haven't
walked back into the kitchen well then
it doesn't suggest that we have it
that's what they're saying I mean this
is insane these are the legal documents
these are legal document this isn't uh
something people made up this isn't like
something people uh uh came up with on X
to be cute these are genuine legal
documents released through the media you
know what I mean they're not only being
hand it's not like the Twitter files
they're not being handed exclusively to
a small group of journalists these are a
wide
ranging uh institutions are publishing
these uh the veracity is not in question
these are real documents and how many
times find out how many times Clinton's
mentioned I believe it's 50 yeah I think
it's like 56 oh pull up yeah it's I
believe it's a 50 to 60 times that the
president of the United States the
ex-president of the United
States the ex CIA director uh ahud
Barack the ex- prime minister of Israel
all of these people were mentioned in
the documents but the
media is now coming out and going but by
the way none of them this doesn't
suggest that they did anything wrong
this just uh you know it's just
something that
happens there they'll pin this whole
thing on David Copperfield by the way
David cop he's going to jail you will
see David Copperfield per walked all of
these billionaires they've mentioned
Dubin and black the Leon the Apollo guy
and Glen Dubin they'll all be fine the
clintons will be fine somehow David
Copperfield this creep
magician that me and my dad you
know we watched him make a train
disappear in the 9s MH on television it
was kind of cool do you remember that I
don't you were young but you know he did
a thing he made a train disappear and
and me and my father watched it maybe
you could find
it and I like David
Copperfield but
apparently
apparently yeah he made this train
vanish what year was this uh it looks
like are we going to get a YouTube
strike for playing this that's a good
point or do you think copperfield's
people are distracted he's got no
problem maybe they're distracted right
now maybe copperfield's media team's
distracted and they're not going to be
reporting people playing as a train
trick I don't
know but I will tell you this apparently
David Copperfield was doing magic you
know you think when you go to a
pedophile orgy that would be all you do
but apparently the epin went the extra
mile he had like fun other things
happening MH can you imagine being a
frustrated pedophile and you're sitting
there and you're like all right like you
know what I mean like uh I get it he's a
big comedian but you know we're here to
you know I mean that's why we took the
plane you know I mean we're all being
blackmailed and videotaped and you know
can we just get to it because like if I
if I see this guy do another card trick
I'm going to kill myself but apparently
that's what Epstein Did You Know It's
never enough just to be a
pimp It's never enough to be anything by
the way this is what's interesting about
life it's one of the great human
comedies where it's never enough so you
have this guy who's a a like a pimp
Jeffrey Epstein's a pedophile pimp and
everyone coming to that island now I
know the media would disagree with my
crazy General ization right because of
course there were people that went to
the island to see the fauna and the
Flora but uh let's just say that a good
90 some odd percent of them were there
to kids that's why they're going
and Jeffrey Epstein is he's created this
island pedophile Paradise for all of
these people but it's not enough because
he goes well you know he goes but I I
want them that I want them that I want
this to be a weekend they'll never never
forget and you go well no you know
probably even jlan was probably like no
no no darling they they're going to love
it we go we go everything I got all
these girls we're bringing them in he
goes no no no but what if what about it
a magic show and she's all really know
we need I don't darling I don't know if
we have we've got all these we've got
all these children from Bad homes and
they're going to they're going to
all these people and darling they're
going to love it and he's like yeah but
I just want more
I want I want people to talk about this
I don't want this just to be you know
the same old pedophile orgies that
they've always been doing in Washington
I want
magic I want fun what about a tarot card
what about a tarot card reader how about
a tarot card reader what about a fun
carnival you know some circus games it
might fit the theme of being
pedophiles how about uh that uh fun
thing where you know the water gun and
the clowns mouth jlane can we make it
fun shouldn't we have it a little more
fun here I you know they don't want it
and then there's probably these
pedophiles that are like and this guy
Jeffrey was insufferable too he started
talking about science and seeding the
human race with his DNA and can you
imagine that you you shove to the
pedophile Island and then Stephen
Hawkings there and Jeffrey EP is like so
we're doing a talk about uh physics with
step Hawking and then we're David
Copperfield I is making a a tree
disappear and then we'll all the
kids people are going hey man um not for
nothing but can we get a move on
this it is hilarious because he was a a
pedophile pimp I mean none of that's
funny but just the idea that it wasn't
enough he wanted to be known he wanted
to hang out with like scientists and he
thought he was like a bon vant you he
was a pimp he was like you know the
people people that you noticed uh or or
that you didn't you know you would see
in New York City when I was growing up
like these guys with fur coats or
leather coats or you know big Cadillacs
and then they'd have the hookers
standing in Time Square that's all
Jeffrey Epstein was all he was as a pimp
but he had delusions of grandeur like
anyone
else anyone else because the Mad in the
CIA kept you know pushing him and he was
blackmailing all these people and they
were kind of like you know they had his
back up until when they didn't but he
had all these delusions of grandeur it's
like you know he wanted to have all
these scientists hang out at his house
he wanted to hang out with Bill
Gates and uh he wanted to pick their
brains and he really fancied himself as
this guy who was on The Cutting Edge but
he was just a pimp that's the thing
magician David Copperfield had dinner
with Jeffrey EP and asked victim if she
realized Predators girls were getting
paid to find out other girls for him to
abuse so what is what does this mean was
Copperfield saying this like hey what's
up here this incriminates Copperfield
potentially why or maybe he's asking
because he doesn't like this maybe maybe
it's just it's you know he but did he
leave the island after he asked this
question because you know he then he
kind of knows something's going on
either way the documents said go down
here for minute David Copperfield was at
a dinner at Epstein's and there was
another girl present who looked Young
and Joanna asked what school she went to
and Joanna did not recognize the school
name as being a college and she said it
was possible that it was a high
school-aged girl Joanna said Copperfield
questioned me if I was aware that girls
were getting paid to find other
girls
huh then there's all those weird Notes
too like the jackpot thing we saw
earlier yeah get some of those up David
copperfield's notes when he got to the
island
none of this suggests any
wrongdoing David
Copperfield he's like and now my trick I
will make these 15-year-old girls
disappear so this is weird yeah this is
odd this is an important
message uh Mr David Copperfield this is
for
Jeffrey time
5:36 I guess AM or PM I can't see
he will be receiving later arriving
later and he will be expecting he'll be
arriving later he will be expecting he
will be arriving later and he will be
expecting for Jeffrey Epstein David
Copperfield the date my birthday January
22nd 2005 I was of course not born in
2005 I was born in uh
1902 but uh the message
for Jeffrey Epstein from
someone speaking on behalf of David
Copperfield
yes it's jackpot right is the message
it's
jackpot I don't know what that means but
I'll tell you this it doesn't suggest
any
wrongdoing it doesn't it doesn't if you
just cuz you've sent a human trafficker
a message of visiting his Island does
not suggest it's NBC is telling you it
does not suggest any wrong dut now if
Donald Trump infl inflates the price of
a condo by 80 grand he should be given
the death penalty but NBC is letting us
know that it's just not that big of a
deal none of this is that big of a deal
the messages to visiting the pretty soon
by the way the new spin on this because
the spin already the media is doing his
kind of brilliant the media is doing
this thing would it go so what so what
because the me remember the media is all
implicated too the media's compromised
the media's got problems you couldn't
even imagine right so they just have to
come out and we're talking about the
people who own these companies and all
this stuff this everybody knows what's
going on so they are instructing their
anchors to just basically go out and
just basically be like
listen of course
did this is the spin the media is
putting on this which is actually kind
of
hilarious the the spin on this is that
Jeffrey Epstein opened a phone book in
New York City and picked these people's
names out because they sounded
rich and
somehow they ended up in this uh in
these court filings but other than that
we cannot draw any conclusions from this
we can draw no conclusion now remember
it's the same group of
people that if somebody at moral Lago
had a meeting with a guy whose brother
knew a guy who went to Russia and met
Putin shook his hand the Labyrinth of
connections that were being used to
justify this idea that the Russia gate
thing was real this is the same media
that was coming up with the you know the
steel dossier these memos these the piss
tape all these weird conspiracies that
were like held together by essentially
nothing right conjecture and all of this
Stu downright lies all of this stuff
kind of being packaged together um
they're now telling you that actual
credible genuine
evidence documents from a court don't
really suggest anything they don't mean
anything and by the way they're not
going to find find out what it means
this is the other thing that the the
media is basically going like this hey
hey guys uh we don't know what it means
and you don't know what it means and
we're not going to try to find out what
it means so we'll just all live with the
mystery we don't know this doesn't
suggest any
wrongdoing would you think that it's
enough to maybe start investigating a
little of the wrongdoing do you think
that's uh enough but they're not doing
any of that their job pretty assume it's
coming where they're going to say
visiting the island was not a thing
either they're going to go so what yeah
people went to an island that doesn't
mean
anything yes they went to a pedophile
orgy Island but it's not it doesn't mean
that anything was going
on the only one who did anything was
David Copper they're gonna tell they're
gonna come on the TV and they're going
to say that David Copperfield ran this
whole
operation and that Clinton was there to
stop David Copperfield from molesting
the girls that's what we're going to be
told Bill Clinton found out about this
and he went to that Island 25 times to
try to shut it down to try to stop it
bill and his lesbian wife got on the
plane to try to stop it from happening
because he was chasing David but it was
so hard to keep chasing David Copper
field cuz David kept making Epstein's
jet disappear so that's why Clinton had
to keep going back to the island to shut
it down this is what the media is going
to do they're going to do this over the
next couple of days and weeks they're
going to do this they're going to go
hey they're gonna go we are just a
gas at what is that Happ but we just
cannot believe it we don't understand
get some other
random media coverage get a CBS get
anybody up
there because I've been watching
watching some of these and it really
doesn't matter which one you watch I
mean Fox might be a little different but
the tenor of the coverage and I don't
even know if Fox is that different the T
because there's a lot of Republicans
implicated in this
too here we go so this is CB here's the
good people at CBS News let's see what
they're doing naming people connected to
Jeffrey Epstein have been unsealed the
documents include nearly 950 Pages last
month a federal judge ruled the names of
Epstein's alleged victims and those
connected to him must be made public
Epstein was indicted on federal sex
trafficking charges in 2019 he later
died by Suicide publication does not
imply knowledge of his alleged crimes or
involvement in them the names are part
of a lawsuit right F F this is by the
way this is line number one this is line
one in every news thing line one they
don't get to it later first of all died
by Suicide repeated that lie we all know
know it's a lie we know the you know the
the guards were asleep or
whatever there were every we all know
the whole thing his Sate was a you know
I'm not even going to rehash it but we
know but it's again CBS going a
publication does not imply knowledge of
his crimes now here's the deal here's
the deal
okay in what other news case have they
done this in what other case and by the
way I'm not saying that everybody in the
documents is guilty that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying in what other news
case do they feel the need to go out and
say just because these names are being
bandied about doesn't mean they did
anything wrong this is the first thing
they say MH in what other news case does
the president an ex-president of the
United States mentioned over 50 times in
these documents the first thing you say
is well there's nothing illegal here
nobody knows anything no you have to
believe that all of this is an accident
that all of these people are just an
accident it's a complete accident that
they're all being
mentioned they had no idea they had no
idea they had no idea what are you
talking about these are the wealthiest
people in the world they can go anywhere
they
want on
vacation okay they can go anywhere they
want they the richest people in the
world they can go anywhere they
want they lead
countries they can go
anywhere this is not a bunch of my
friends from Long Island who would just
go the French Virgin Islands
really this is the wealthiest people in
the
world they do not need to go to this
island there's no reason they're going
to this island island with this
guy this is not there they can travel
they can Charter planes they have other
friends with planes the people in the
media act like Jeffrey Epstein owned the
one private plane available from 2005 to
2020 it's like that's not there's a
whole industry I have a lovely jet
broker named Dirk he's a large man from
Boa rone he can get you private
jet the Epstein is not the only guy with
the jet this idea that he's the only
person with a jet the media looks
straight in the face go there's no
indication that anybody on the chat did
anything wrong people need to take Jets
what are they going to do walk where are
they gonna go so it's interesting that
it's the F it's not only that they're
saying it they're not saying it at the
end they're saying it in the
beginning they're saying it in the
beginning because they're going to claim
they're they're all afraid of
vigilantism and vigilante justice and I
understand the mob Justice is not good
now they this is the reason that they're
coming out with these disclaimers
they're going to say that they're going
to go well people are endangered by
their names being out
there and there's some truth to that so
why don't you do the work of figuring
out who did who did
it why don't you do the work of figuring
out why the ex-president's name who's
going to be fine at Secret Service
protection he's fine and these billion
I'm not worried about these billionaires
by the way I'm not really worried about
the guy that runs high it right isn't he
name the guy who runs Hyatt are we're
worried about the guy who runs Hyatt his
safety it's not true these are the same
people that don't care at all about
remember those dumb uh story about those
Covington kids they were doxing them
they weren't concerned about the safety
of those kids they weren't concerned
about the safety of anybody they don't
care about the safety this is a
hilarious angle by the way it's a
hilarious angle well we the safety of
the people named in the do they don't
care they don't care about due process
they don't care about safety they don't
care about anything the media is driven
by only likes uh clicks
shares eyeballs views this is what they
do this is all that they do this is how
they stay alive so when they come out
and they go well we just want to let you
know that all of the people named here
it has nothing to do with the EP being a
human trafficker this is just people
that kind of knew him and and I'm sure
some of that is true I'm sure there's a
guy that was like what's going on if
there's always some guy that gets roped
into something and he's sitting there
going wait a minute what there are
people that ended up in places they
shouldn't have been but it's not all of
them and it's probably not even um the
majority of like there's probably a lot
of people I'm not saying that there
aren't people that just were on the jet
or whatever but when you're talking
about repeat trips to the island you're
talking
about people asking questions people
visiting and hanging out with this guy
after he'd already been convicted of um
the first uh massage gone wrong which
again he was just basically like I got a
massage from this and she lied
about her age you know you know these
girls are always lying and massaging
you finish a little bit let's see a
little bit more of how they handle this
the great people CBS News just want to
let you know that everything's
good galain Maxwell who was sentenced to
20 years in prison for sex trafficking
young girls for Epstein CBS News
correspondent Nancy Chen joins me now
okay Nancy there's a lot to sift through
what do you know there is we are going
through this right now we have a team
combating attacking this big document
relase just got 40 documents in total uh
more than as you mentioned
940 Pages plus we have a team going
through this right now we'll make sure
to bring you updates but here's what we
do know it's important to not that being
named as you mentioned does not
necessarily mean that someone had
knowledge of or involvement in absence
of
Crime Stop that Nancy Chen now coming in
here hot Nancy's coming in hot she's
coming in
hot she's like I just want to reiterate
to the retards who watch this
network many of you are old you got
pills falling out of your mouths you're
drooling you're basically dead what we
want to let you know for the 19th time
we're coming in
hot none of this means that anyone did
anything wrong these are just names on a
piece of paper like your name could be
on it or your friend's name could be on
it no one did anything no one did
nothing here this is separate there's
Jeffrey Epstein the human trafficker and
then there's this thing that we got
which is a whole another thing that's
the way the media is handling this this
is
different this is a whole another thing
let's continue with Nancy
Chen of accusers along with potential
Witnesses underage accusers were kept
under seal here uh that said nearly 190
J Do's were mentioned uh in these
documents they're tied to a civil
lawsuit against EP Epstein's accomplice
galain Maxwell who is now serving as you
mentioned a 20-year prison sentence for
helping Epstein groom and sexually abuse
underage girls her accuser Virginia du
fre says she was trafficked when she was
17 to Britain's prince Andrew who has
denied her allegations they settled out
of court in 2022 but EPC a convicted sex
offender died by su suicide in jail in
2019 while awaiting trial for sex
trafficking I do want to point out that
two people connected to today's release
have asked for their names to stay under
seal and a judge granted those requests
temporarily as their objections remained
under review so we're going to continue
going through this there's a lot to sift
through and we'll make sure you as it
they said nothing okay it's it's amazing
how they they say nothing they go
there's a lot there's a lot there's a
lot to go through here we got a crack
team in the back by the way wait does
anyone believe that does anyone does
anyone believe that CBS News has a team
of people going through these documents
does anyone gun to your head you know
what it is right you go in the back of
CBS News there's like a fat guy he's
eating you know it's New York they're
all New York he's eating like a like a
like a you know like a a pin wheel from
a pizzeria like a pepperoni pin wheel
and it's kind of like he's like pulled
it apart and the cheese is kind of
concealed it's kind of gross and he's
like dunking it in the sauce and she's
kind of gy at it like a rat wood and
he's got this uh you know he's got like
the Epstein all the docks up and like
it's his job to like make sense out of
this that's the best case scenario it's
like one they they put one fat idiot on
it and they're like what do you think
and he's like oh no there's a lot of
people named in here a lot of
people getting up over there it's
not a correct Twitter's ripped it all
apart X sorry X has of course Broken it
down
quicker I gave a quote to Barry Weiss in
the Free Press I did a little funny joke
Barry Weiss and the Free Press will be
printing that if they don't print it I
will sue them because I wrote
it but uh we'll we'll be moving on
shortly from this story but this is uh
interesting it is develop Ving and I I
just want to say that when I while I
cover this story I want to let my
audience know my viewers my listeners
people that have listened to this show
some of them seven or eight years
um that just because I'm talking about
the names of these people that have been
mentioned it does not imply that I think
they did anything wrong I think they're
all fine upstanding people I think
they're all great people I think it's
probably a situation where there's some
type of
accident that happened where they all
ended up on a human trafficker Island
multiple times it happens it
happens it h layovers you know
happens I wanted to as a sad story now
Lisa's Lounge this is a a bar in Long
Island New
York I spent many of my formative years
here many fans of this show know about
Le L's
Lounge because it is something that I
have talked about at nauseum in the
early
episodes to all my so this is uh this is
two days ago somebody shared this with
me from a Facebook group I did not know
Lisa's Lounge was on Facebook I didn't
follow them to all my Lisa Lounge family
and friends after 22
years the doors are officially closed
for Good we wanted to take the time to
thank all the patronage and bartenders
that have helped us Thrive over the
years we are now on to a new year and a
new chapter happy New Year and cheers to
the Future and then can you make that
picture big
yeah and this is a little celebration I
believe they had the end there's the end
of Lisa's lounge and that's sad isn't it
man I wish I stayed there huh well there
it is the end of Lisa's
Lounge a great place I used to sit at
that bar and drink almost a bottle of
vodka every
night wow
well we wish everyone well maybe that'll
be their last night of drinking and then
after that all right take it down please
take it down it's giving me flashbacks
doing stress I want to say that no one
in that photo just because they're in
that photo does not mean that they're
consuming alcohol Andor doing cocaine
just because they're in that photo that
doesn't mean that's what they're doing
it does not suggest that's the
activities that are happening we don't
know this crazy article I read 200 hours
to maintain your and by the way just
before I say goodbye to leisa's
Lounge I will say that everyone in their
life at one point I do not trust you if
you haven't had a a a watering
hole some type of dirt bag bar I don't
trust people that only uh uh frequent
clubs or
lounges or uh you know high-end
establishments my father said to me once
when I was telling him I was like an
alcoholic he said listen every a dirt
big bar he goes a corner bar has played
a role in every Dylan's life he goes I
was like well that's not really a have a
real problem he's like your uncle Tommy
had Buckley he goes I had a place called
The Bitter End I'm like that's not but
okay but I will say this uh I will say
this about having a good dirt bag
bar you learn a lot about the world from
places like that there is this idea in
our culture now that the only uh place
you can learn things from is uh the the
number one the digital
space or even more
importantly uh you could only learn
things from successful people this is
like the
real uh
interesting
because it wasn't always like that by
the way all of these parables in the
Bible and you know literature forever
has focused on like you know a lot of
the greatest literary characters Don
kote uh Willie lman any of these people
right they've been failures they've been
uh you know delusional they've been
miscreant they've been near duells but
now we're we're only learning anything
from like successful people or people
that pretend to be successful and that's
kind of unfortunate because a a a a good
Corner Bar a good Gin Mill a good
watering Hall will show you how not to
live it's important to know how not to
live it's important to know what giving
up is it's important to know truly
really it's important to know what it
looks like when you let the things that
you battle with win it's important to
know what it feels like um to have uh no
absolutely no uh fight left in you and
that's what a lot of those bars will
open your eyes up to because again the
first few times you go it really is a
lot of fun and everybody's Goofy and
silly and people are laughing maniacally
it's they're charged up it's it's it's a
mad house in those places
because that is it for those people
people that is it you might be stopping
in
ironically or you might be going in to
see what the deal is their lives are
that bar they are there as much as they
can be
247 so they're in their element they're
having an uncomfortable amount of fun
sometimes um and then when they have
breakdowns and they get really sad
they're also there they don't leave they
don't go away to have their moments
everything the whole tapestry of Life
the highs and lows are there and you
know it's good to see what that is like
and I did it when I was in my early to
mid 20s and then got out of that and
decided I wanted to have another life
which I also
recommend but I will say this I don't
regret the time I
spent sitting in that bar drinking out
alcohol with
people doing
cocaine you
know and talking about nothing because
that's what those bars are you you don't
really talk about
anything I'd sit in
there people's children would come in
crying and
go they they try you know a woman would
come in and she'd try to drag her
husband out she'd be like you've been
here three days you have a daughter you
disgust me and he'd be like like
you get out of here and the girl the
daughter the 11-year-old daughter would
be behind him behind her and he'd be
like I can't believe you're using her to
come in here and make a
point and then she'd leave and the the
kid and her are crying and she'd leave
and the guy looks at me he goes she's
very selfish I go I can tell I can see
how she'd be a problem and I go that was
very performative bringing the daughter
in here I go I don't like that one bit
and he goes I agree and then we would
you know do shots and drink it is a nice
time to kind of connect with different
people but you should
learn
exactly where your threshold is where is
your limit how big of a piece of
are you willing to be David Carr who was
a media reporter for the New York Times
wrote a book called The Night of the gun
he's smoking crack he's looking at his
two kids in the back of the car David
Carr said I was prepared to be a bad
person but I wasn't prepared to be a bad
father a lot of the people I hung out
with were prepared to be bad fathers but
they weren't prepared to not be fun cuz
they were fine cold turkey may be great
on sandwiches but there's a better way
to break your bad habits we're not
talking about some weird mind voodoo
from your crazy neighbor we're talking
about our sponsor
fume and they look at the problem in a
different way not everything in a bad
habit is wrong so instead of drastic
uncomfortable change why not just remove
the bad from your habit fume is an
Innovative award-winning flavored air
device that does just that instead of
vapor fume used flavored Air instead of
electronics fume is completely natural
and instead of harmful chemicals fume
uses delicious
flavors it's very interesting I've used
this everyone I know has used it and
everybody I know is incredibly happy
with it and it's changing all their bad
habits and bad behaviors right now is
the best time to start the good habit
with fume all orders between January 1st
to the 14th have buy one get one cores
so you can stock up for that New Year's
resolution plus as a listener of the
show you get an extra 10% off when you
use our code head to trif nume.com and
use my code Tim for an additional 10%
off BOGO cores until January 14th to
help make starting the good habit that
much easier blue is unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra Calis and licha
but in a chewable tablet at a fraction
of the cost you can take them anytime
day or night you can plan ahead or be
ready whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at blue.com
consult with one of their licensed
medical providers and once you're
approved to receive your prescription
within days the best part it's hold done
online so no visits to the doctor's
office no walk conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy bluetoth
tablets are made in the USA and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package blueo wants to help you
have better
sex discover your options at blu.com
chew it and do it and we've got a
special deal for our listeners try blueo
free when you use our promo code Tim at
checkout try blueo free when you use
promo code Tim at checkout just pay $5
shipping that's B true.com
Chu promo code Tim to receive your first
month free visit blu.com for more
details and important safety information
I we thank blue for sponsoring the
podcast this article makes no sense it
takes at least 200 hours to make a close
friendship and more to maintain it this
is completely insane what what what uh
is this what is this the Wall Street
Journal yeah yeah so whenever the Wall
Street Journal writes an article like
this by the way it is simply trying to
get you to buy stocks or something like
the Wall Street Journal has no interest
in social behavior outside of the
Paradigm of capitalism they don't care
they don't care it does not interest or
Fascinate them so whenever they put this
stuff out it's like when Bloomberg or
Barons or any of these Financial things
writes about culture it's always
because they want
you in some way to be a better unit of
production and this is why they're
writing it they're not writing it
because they have like an interest in
your spiritual life you know you know
that article that came out where they
were like you don't need dining rooms
they're dining rooms going out of style
who needs hallways you know just have a
door from one room to the next like
they're doing that so you get used to
less and less and you walk into a in a
house one day that's going to look like
a shelter and you go that's fine because
I read that no one needs dining rooms
anymore there preparing you for the type
of Life they they kind of want you to
live many of us worry that we don't put
in enough time to maintain close
friendships but how much is enough as we
Trek further into adulthood many of our
friends fall away it's understandable
family and jobs become more demanding
and free time more limited yeah because
of the Wall Street
Journal we may want to meet a close
friend for coffee or dinner but our
calendars are full with work work must
do appointments meetings or kids
activities about 88% of us adults say
they have lost touch with a close friend
at some point and 71% would like to
rekindle that relationship according to
a 2020
survey huh four in 10 Americans have
said they didn't have a best friend at
all this is the epidemic of loneliness
this is a big thing now by the way this
is a big deal we're reading about this
all the time research on the science of
friendship ship does offer some insights
that can help you maintain friendships
among the lessons be realistic about how
many good friendships you can reasonably
maintain and then they go into the
science of friendship
huh unfort I like this unfortunately for
the hyper efficient Among Us there's no
magic formula for how much time you need
to spend on your friends to keep them
can you
imagine the sickness of this art like in
the insanity of this article how insane
this is is this is a sentence I'm going
to read again this is in the Wall Street
Journal someone printed this in the Wall
Street
Journal this is not like a a paper that
is you know in a in a in a you line a
litter box with it's the W Street
Journal unfortunately for the hyper
efficient amongst us Among Us there's no
magic formula for how much time you need
to spend on your friends to keep them
each friend ship and friend is unique
and thrives or Withers depending on how
we interact hey thanks
guys thanks so
much one of the most powerful papers in
the world that has
decided by the way during a time when we
have a war in the Middle East where
30,000 people are killed I believe the
vast majority of them children that we
are
bankrolling we have a we're about to go
to war uh with the yemeni houthi rebels
or
whatever the global balance of power is
Shifting and realigning all the time we
are in now in 34 trillion do worth of
debt as a country The Wall Street
Journal a paper who's created a lot of
these problems is writing about
buddies they're writing articles about
your buddy and where your buddy where's
my buddy go hey where did my where did
there are they're
killing children in Gaza right now at a
pace that is like un even Jewish people
now are going
hey they're choosing to write it about
where was your buddy go did your buddy
leave where did your buddy go oh your
buddy got on a different bus and he
moved to a different town this is
written for fivey old what's
happening is like all of these articles
are written now like they're like let's
pretend you were a human being they're
written like you're already Ai and
you're becoming a human listen to this
in order to move from casual friends to
close friends you need to spend an
additional 140 to 160 hours together for
a total of about 200 hours that's
completely untrue
that is a complete lie that is
completely untrue that is not true I
have close friends and I've not spent
200 hours with them that's completely
untrue conversely spending 200 hours
together doesn't necessarily mean a
person will become a close friend of
course it doesn't who is who is this for
who is writing these articles at the
Wall Street like there's nothing else
going
on 200 members of the ruling class just
got exposed in the document is potential
pedophiles at the Wall Street Journal is
like the you and your buddy have
lunch sometimes your buddy won't like
the lunch you
like I'm I don't know why I'm doing an
Adam Sandler voice but it just feels
correct but it is insane that this is
what they're choosing to write about and
this is all cockamamy science it's not
true this is there's no science this is
not science you have to spend 200 hours
with someone before they like you that's
not
science when it comes to maintaining
friendships it's not just the number of
hours you spend together but what you do
that
matters Hall says based on Research what
research I mean this is
crazy send that text here's what it
comes down to here's what they want send
that
text we we generally don't need to
maintain friendships with one of our two
best friends says sociologist Jan yger
researches friendships and has written
several books on the subject she
frequently texts or calls her best
friend from college who lives about
three hours
away it's important she says to
recognize you are truly bus D D
D here's the thing with friendships they
all have Golden Ages this is the truth
there are certain friends that you have
for a very long time there's but you're
never you never quite recapture the
Golden Age of your friendship this is
completely normal in life it's normal
that your circle uh gets smaller and I
know there is an epidemic of of
loneliness in the country and a lot of
that's because our lives are digital now
and a lot of th those lives are empty
and unfulfilling and digital communities
aren't uh the most supportive fulfilling
and you know I guess maybe the answer I
guess will be they're going to be become
more immersive and then they will feel
more real but as of right now that's
kind of empty it's not um it's not
seeing people and being face to face and
being and you know there's a book
bowling Alone written about this and
it's a pretty good book about you know
the collapse of like those social
communities that you know held people
together whether it was Knights at
Columbus or whatever but it's just funny
that this is the most obvious article
that anyone could write about anything
and and and growing up and and evolving
and you learn all this stuff and I just
don't know why these papers now are
treating us like we're
six I don't think that's a good
that that that big uh papers right now
are treating us like we're
six like it's a very strange Dynamic the
way they're speak this is the Wall
Street Journal people who read this have
a little bit going on this is not like
the New York Post or something this is
like the Wall Street Journal where it's
like the people who read this are
supposed to be like higher and they're
like sometimes your friend moves away
and you don't have that friend anymore
it's it's like guys why are we focusing
an inordinate amount of words on this uh
very uh understandable concept that
friendships change and some of them get
better or worse over time and by the way
that's every relationship in your life
that's uh your wife your husband your
family it's all about the time you put
in I just don't it's such a strange
thing this is not
only this particular article it's a
whole Spate of these articles now that
are being
written like we are like it's terrifies
me this article is in the Wall Street
Journal how scary it is they will write
about anything except Epstein they will
write about anything except this I mean
the social science of
friendships when was this published a
couple of days ago is a long time ago uh
yesterday two days ago yesterday two
days
ago they're like yeah you know we just
want to
uh listen to this ready go go up a
little bit
here Arthur Aaron a research professor
in the department of psychology at
Stonybrook University developed a
procedure to study interpersonal
closeness in the lab researchers
provided pairs of strangers three sets
of in increasingly personal questions
for example they might start with when
did you last s yourself and progressed
to when did you last cry in front of
another person they found that strangers
in this fast fr study could
establish interpersonal closeness in 45
minutes the takeaway was that sharing
things about yourself can lead to close
friendships I mean can you imagine this
is can you imagine this the
takeaway the takeaway is that sharing
things about yourself can lead the CL I
mean this is like this is mindblowing I
was reading this going like is this real
are we is this is this AI are they like
trying out a system to write articles
like this is the Wall Street Journal
telling you that sharing close stuff can
make you friend oh yeah yeah duh this is
crazy once that closeness is established
Aaron says that some ways to maintain
closeness are supporting friends when
things go wrong for them and celebrating
their achievements this is for the
robots this has got to be for this has
got to be for like autonomous human Bots
and they're just they're just writing it
and they're throwing it in the Wall
Street Journal it it it terrifies me
that this is how stupid people are
getting that we we need articles like
this or that articles like this
automatically don't become jokes
MH I'll tell you this this is another
thing that I've been thinking about as
we head into this um election because
Joe Biden is uh out there he's
campaigning at uh some some not too uh
Happy places he's
going he's going into uh Biden kick off
2024 by delving into some of the
country's darkest moments the Associated
Press that's nice a lot of people think
the move when you are running a
presidential campaign is to be uh
positive and and remind people that uh
you are a positive
force um that's not the case uh this guy
is going to Valley Forge
Pennsylvania where George Washington in
the Continental Army spent a bleak
winter near 250 years ago okay then he's
going to Mother Emanuel Church in
Charleston where nine people were shot
and killed in a June 15 white
supremacist
attack oh boy it's not exactly the Fun
Run is it no he's going to some really
Bleak
places well I think he's leaning into
this idea you know he's old he's
decrepit it would I guess be weird to
see him at like the opening of a Six
Flags so he's going to a gym I mean he's
going to a
church where there was a massacre and
he's going to Valley
Forge it's dark it's it's it's G to be
an interesting election I like that's
where we're starting it here yeah this
is our Baseline our Baseline is the the
mother Emanuel Church Valley Forge a lot
of people Di here lot of death that's
how he's kicking it off MH he's kicking
off with a lot of death and he's going
to remind people that things are bad
things can get a lot worse that's what
he's going to remind people he's goingon
to remind people that I'm running for
president because horrible things have
happened that's the that's the that's
the that seems to be the campaign's
early Focus I'm running for president
because terrible things have happened in
this country country and they could
happen again and that's why I'm here to
run for president because I am all that
is standing be between you and more
Terrible Things Terror you what's that
line from Game of Thrones the night is
dark and full of Terrors Joe Biden 2024
the night is dark you get that Priestess
from Game of Thrones that's who should
do the commercial She's Like the Lord of
Light the Lord of Light the night is
dark and full of Terrors Biden 2024
that's where he's uh that's where he's
starting he's starting there where do
you go if you start at Valley Forge only
up only up you'd think you would think
Gettysburg yeah he might he might it
might get even worse he might leave the
country you might see the next
commercial he does might be from as
schwitz you know I'm Jo Biden here at
out schtz you know like that might be
where he goes he might just go to the
scene of mass Graves everywhere which I
support I may vote for him if Joe Biden
conducts an entirely Mass grave campaign
it'll be hard not to get my vote because
it's just where I live you know so if he
just for every week if he's broadcasting
from the sight of another Massacre like
if he's like and this is where the
commandes uh you know just killed all
the settlers cut their throats and they
all bled out even the babies even the
babies if he somehow finds a way to do
that it'll be difficult to uh you
know to
not to not get a little bit excited but
that's an interesting strategy like
people in strategy room are like listen
they think you're old they think you're
out of touch here's what we'll do you
need to show them that uh horrible
things happen horrible horrible horrible
terrible things because when people are
thinking about these horrible terrible
things you will seem by comparison not
such a big deal that you don't know
where you are or what you're saying but
we need to remind people how Bleak it
can get so that you seem uh like The
Logical choice because he is The Logical
choice if that is the country that
you're in every day in your head the the
the the tragedy at that church was
horrible by the way and that kid should
have been executed I don't know if who
was or
not but if that's where you live like if
you wake up every day and that's the
mentality you're in and or you're
thinking somehow about the rough winter
that the Continental Army had at Valley
Forge if that's where you are mentally
then I think that's the the Biden
campaign wants you to be there that's
where they want you to be they want you
to be in a place
where um you know there's Darkness out
there and it's coming for you and you
just got to you just got to not let it
Eat You Alive and the only way to not
let it Eat You Alive is kind of like Joe
Biden's being put out there as like The
Giver there was that book that Lois
Lowry wrote that all these young we all
read when we were young kids and it was
this one guy who takes all the pain of
the world and that's now Joe Biden this
elderly dementia ridden man is being
paraded in front of these Mass Graves to
tell people that yes horrible nasty
terrible things happen but don't worry
about it he's got it he's got it he's
the one he breathes in the terror he
knows what it's like he's going to
protect
you it would be
hilarious if Joe
Biden gets up at Valley Forge or that
church and he starts talking about like
the Epstein thing thing and he goes you
know a lot of names came out Jeffrey EP
you know he'll say he's a bad dude he
say he's a bad dude but he'll go but but
because people had their names mentioned
does not imply that they did anything
wrong they they did not you got to
understand man that just CU those people
are mentioned they didn't do anything
wrong and then everyone's like okay that
makes a lot of sense
thank you so much and this is the The
Joe Biden graveyard campaign Trump is
kind of Legally now trying to get
himself on the
ballot one guy is trying to get himself
back on the ballot because he's being
kicked off the ballot because he's got
issues the other guy is starting his
campaign stops at the the scene of mass
death it's gonna be a fun fun
season got to be a fun fun
Season watching all of this play out
gonna be very very interesting Tim
Dillan comedy.com we're on the
road uh go there get tickets we're not
going to bother you and tell you where
we're going to be it's gonna it'll be
annoying to keep reading those
dates you you support us we're doing
very well we are added to our third show
in Boston come see us at the Wilbur
Theater and we love everybody here we
love all of
you if your friend your
friend if you're friends with your
friend they'll be your
friend and uh we'll watch the Epstein
story continue to develop and as always
we will rely on the analysis of a uh
disinterested and uh compromised media
who will be a lot of fun in the cold uh
months of January not too cold anymore
actually it's kind of nice in New York
people wearing shorts nice nice nice
well you know I was so I wanted my dad's
name or someone to be mentioned in those
Epstein Docks but my nearo well parents
again have failed me and how cool would
it have been you know it's like it would
have been like shitty that he was a
pedophile but I would have been like wow
really
really if he went anywhere French I'd be
uh proud you know good night